but why is the default that the woman is
innocent and the man is always
guilty okay there's something my wife
wants to say uh Sal probably had enough
as woman give out give a lot of chances
has zero tolerance now okay this is why
I want you here yeah it's very important
for you to be
here from black resin I do
bodybuilding boxing calisthenics I run
out of energy git is a natural substance
found in the Himalayas created by
entries of grass and organisms
decomposing into a thick black goo which
makes it very potent it's like a tar
light product you just get a little bit
of this onto the spoon so you can get
hot water not too hot inah so it can
disintegrate into the water also there
is some studies that show it boost test
even helps the respiratory system as
well buy yours now brother sisters go to
the description box in and use my
discount code let's see stronger better
more focused Muslim men who are serving
their lord and their families and their
wives and their children
inam brothers and sisters and dear
friends this video will be a very unique
video a very special video should you
want to say uh it's a video that if it
does come out public it means that I
have spoken to people of knowledge
spoken to my peers my friends and uh got
something toere from them and gone ahead
with it why am I saying this because I
have my wife on my right
alikum hope you we're going to come to
you why my wife is here why is she in
the video she's not going to be in the
video but she's going to have her say um
with this whiteboard that I B to her
we'll come to what that is about in a
minute so I'll be doing a reaction video
pertaining to the issue of um sister Sal
and if I'm not mistaken is that what
they're called yeah yeah okay so
basically they um from what we've heard
is that they have divorced uh or they
gone their separate ways we don't know
the matter we don't know the ins and
details out of it but the biggest threat
one of the biggest threats should I say
we have to the um in today's time is
divorce rates divorce is something that
is breaking the family unit it is
destroying households it have it has an
effect on kids it has an effect on the
mental well-being of the wife the mental
well-being of the husband usually with
these things men tend to suffer more
because we don't have the cop coping
mechanism that our wives do which is you
know crying expressing women speak to
tend to speak more than men they express
the self more than men they use more
words than we do so they have that
mechanism with us men we keep it inside
bottle it bottle it until it explodes
and when we look at suicide rates um men
and women equally harm themselves but
men take more lethal Force which causes
them to end their life so this is the
reason I'm doing this video and I
thought is very very important that to
have the female perspective as you guys
know on the B truth show and this has
been something that I've always done I
always want to understand the point from
a sister's point of view so that's the
reason why I brought my wife into this
how she's going to be expressing herself
and that's out of her choice um not that
there's anything wrong with her being on
camera but I don't like my private life
not that I'm sharing my private life
with you guys anyways but the point is
that she's going to be writing some
points down which she she may disagree
with me or she might add on to a point
she's going to write it down and she
will present that to me after I have had
my take on this matter in and then we
can talk about what are the key lessons
we can learn of this issue and we are
going to make Dua for them that Allah
subh brings them back together inshallah
because we don't want to see any Muslim
couple for that matter divorcing or even
non-muslims because it affects the
society that we live in at
large everything
life I don't know if I chose
chose
me andd same thing I knew love
twice something very very important
I will be miserable when they leave
me need a very strong mom to say
that no no no no you did that to me
thank you so much
but HEI when you said you I'm
accountable I want to fix
myself I'm in control
do so I can't change people but I can
change people you can't change people
but I can change people how remove them
replace them my energy I have to protect
it that's why I'm isolated 247 people
think I have social life
and people can't sit with themselves
because they're
scared they don't want to face
themselves I've been
there it's necessary and I just sit with
myself and I know who I
am so guys we watch that video with my
wife as you can see in there's a few
things that I want to mention Subhan
Allah to you guys so a lot of us then we
look at these public figures and we have
this dream world that we set for
ourselves you know why because we want
the reason we project that is because
this is something we want to believe we
want to believe that marriage is all
hunky dory happy like you'll see the
videos you know it's all like jokey oh
my gosh you know and then we carry those
false expectations onto our marriages
and thinking that that's how it's
supposed to be and when it is not then
we get disappointed it's like me going
to a Ferrari and saying can you produce
produce strawberry cheesecakes and it
doesn't I get angry at the Ferrari I'm
like what is wrong with you the Ferrari
is not programmed or created to make
strawberry cakes so my expectation is
always going to be in disappointment so
that is the reason why I totally
disagree with public figures
specifically showing their private life
on camera even having my wifey on the
right on my right hand side may Allah
bless and preserve her it was so much
for me should I do it should I do it
because I'm not even mention my private
life you know nothing about my private
life and I don't even do know anything
about it it's nothing to do with you
zero because I might come and do a
gesture to my wife
and you sister might watch and be like
oh my God she's so romantic why don't
you do that or brothers might watch and
have different expectations with their
wives oh but look how Ali's wife listen
I'm not here to do that I'm here because
I genuinely want to hear if my wife has
an input that is that I would like to
hear from a female perspective because I
might be wrong and I want to hear that
that's the reason why she is here now
guys this is the biggest problem we do
we look at people and public figures are
to blame for this the marriages that are
being destroyed I'm so sorry indirectly
or directly you are playing a role in
destroying marriages because believe me
I can do a vlog with my wife oh we're
going holiday here oh the best version
of our life oh my gosh look at our kids
and we went out today and we had
strawberry desserts and why would I show
you a 10c glimpse of fun that I had with
my family my wife and then you're going
to take that and stretch it into my
marriage of how many years and be like
you know nothing about my marriage so as
public figures we have to a
responsibility and take each other to
account of the things that we show
that's number one number two evil eye
magic and before we started this me and
my wife did our why because it protects
us we're public figures sadly there are
people out there who are jealous they
whatever it is for that matter I don't
know what they're jealous about for that
matter yeah and they are just envious
people are in bad places no problem
that's the reason why we are very very
careful to how I am with my wife here
like I'm I'm not artificial I'm not
something are taken away but I don't
want to give a misconstrued idea of how
my Dynamics with my wife is and actually
me and my wife we prefer that you guys
think that my wife is not happy and
she's being
oppressed yeah it's good you know why
keep it we don't need to EV we're not
happy at all it's so good no problem you
know why I don't need that from you guys
alhamdulillah the less the worst you
think that is like there was some
comments like oh my gosh I feel sorry
for his wife brilliant just keep it
going my wife is happy with it as well
just carry and feeling sorry for her and
feeling sorry for me whoever is for that
matter number one now we're going to go
to Surah yusu in the Quran why cuz Allah
subhana tells us Yu when he saw the sun
and the moon and the stars and he came
to his father and spoke of that dream
and his father obviously may have had
some inspiration of understanding dreams
that YF Alam was gifted with that and he
said what to his son do not tell who
your friends people that are watching
you whatever it is yeah um if you live
in today's time don't tell your
followers yeah and don't tell your
neighbors don't tell your brothers blood
blood blood yes do not tell them why
because brothers and sisters envy and
jealousy and hassad these things are
real when you expose yourself to the
people it is bound to have an effect the
prophet said the evil eye is H and he
pointed to the graves and he said do you
know how many people are dead in their
graves because of evil ey so Point
number one which can harm your marriage
is what evil ey number two
in says what that when harut and marut
was given when they brought s down with
the permission of Allah subh tala what
does Allah subh tal say let's read it
for ourself but the devil's disbelieved
teaching people magic and which was
revealed to two angels at Babylon har
and Mar but they they the two angels do
not did not teach anyone unless they say
we are a trial so do not disbelieve by
practicing magic and yet they learn from
that which they cause separation between
a man and his wife but they do not harm
or cause separation between but they do
not harm anyone except from the
permission of Allah another issue that
we have say black magic as if it is more
powerful than Allah Allah saying it is a
test and a trial do not become
disbelievers by practicing it number two
isn't it unique and specifically I don't
know how you think about this here so
profound that the
it's not used for stopping someone
praying Salah stopping them from giving
Sak stopping them from stopping them
from doing anything but it is
specifically used to cause divorce
between man and his wife I found that so
profound that is the one of the reasons
why I started to bit a truth sh to
combat this disease the reason I'm here
today doing this video is to combat that
because when the family unit breaks down
sister Sal and khed we want to see you
guys back together W I make sincere Dua
that Allah subhana reunites you guys
because I've seen some of Hal's video
I've see some of your videos I don't get
what kind of picture you guys put on
smiling Etc I genuinely believe believe
deep down you both miss each other and
you guys are not happy um that's what I
see okay now I don't know the inner
dynamics of your marriage what happened
I don't know and yes in the video you
said that you know I can't change people
but I can change people meaning if you
cannot change somebody's personality
then you replace them this is another
which I don't know if you're going to
disagree me or not please you can voice
it on your whiteboard in yeah and that's
by her choice I don't want people to say
you know foration allowed to speak Etc
you know you have a right to speak if
you want to yeah okay anything you say
use against me in court so the point is
what
that when when we're talking about this
this attitude that we carry on which is
dangerous and sadly a lot of sisters
have this 80% of the time divorces are
initiated by men women now there's a
whole psychology behind that I don't
really want to get into it however this
attitude of Amazon Prime fast cars fast
hand drives fast food Amazon Prime I
like it I don't like it I send it back
and I'm not seeing this sister done that
but as our sisters please we know you
get emotional we know you say things you
don't mean and in this instance look it
might be a case where there might be
where a sister is genuinely unhappy with
her husband her husband is genuinely it
can be or a man can be genuinely unhappy
as well but the point is this we need to
get rid of this habit of replace now I
understand what she's saying it can be
that it's very in her situation which we
do not know the inner Dynamics by the
way yeah it can be but we really need to
get rid of this habit of I don't like it
I'll replace it who said the one that's
going to come after is going to be
better than the one that went why do we
have this Assumption of the grass is
green on the other side the grass is
maybe AstroTurf maybe it's not and
another issue that I see in the comment
section is this and sisters do this a
lot I'm so sorry again you can disagree
with me um sister here my my wife the
point is this is that always blaming the
man oh I wonder what he did oh oh I
could see he was like this oh she looks
more happier Have You Seen Her pores
have gone her her her skin is shining
better since they've divorced you guys
are little shans you guys are little
shans that break down and destroy the
marriage sisters a lot of sisters that
do this you guys are sadly I'm so sorry
I don't care what anyone says I'm not
here to please anybody dislike me hate
me the point is this though I always see
this in the comment section I don't see
it from men I always see it sadly from
sisters who are criticizing that as if
how do you know she was not the
perpetrator again I'm not saying she was
how do you not know she was the one that
was bullying KH for example or she was
the one I'm just saying that it can be
it can be that KH was doing that but why
is the default that the woman is
innocent and the man is always
guilty okay there something my wife
wants to say uh Sal probably had enough
as woman give out give a lot of chances
has zero tolerance now okay this is why
I want you here yeah it's very important
for you to be here and I'm happy that
you are here thank you very much now
again the assumption that you're making
and maybe a LW sister might be making is
the following that Sal has had enough
can I just ask you a question my dear
wife why is it that maybe it's not that
khed gave her a lot of chances and he's
have he has zero tolerance I I would
like to hear that if you can express it
please because the assumption that
you've made now is literally that Sal
has been fed up and she's been going
through a lot and that's exactly the
point I mentioned so can you please just
vocalize to me why is it that hasn't had
enough why isn't it that just just from
like if we were neutral because I just
believe that you're coming from
one-sided yes I know you're you're a
woman and you can be something emotional
and you can more connect with her and
these things can happen but the thing is
a lot of sisters make this mistake so my
wife is writing probably a reputation
for me now but the point is what a
sisters sometimes we take our past
traumas yeah sisters take their past
traumas of their father or ex-husband
Etc and and project it on other people
so okay she's saying she made the video
not him I don't know his opinion well
exactly there you go okay but that's the
point is this is that just because one
decided to express a feeling and again
it proves my point which is what she is
expressive and she's talking about it he
has has he made any video about it zero
this is the point I'm saying so just
because she has made that vocal and a
lot of people say this and I'm going to
end on this not I don't want this video
to go too long yeah is what but just
because women are more expressive I know
of situations of people in marriage
councils
Islamic which tell me stories of a woman
coming and crying literally crying yes
and saying my husband did this my
husband did that and the brothers there
like bro we feel sorry and we're like we
can't wait to see him and stick it on
him and say look and that's what said if
you want to be a just judge never make a
judgment until you hear the other side
that's why with me I'm trying to keep it
more neutral some people are bias yeah
I'm joking yeah but the point is what
when you this this is what was told him
by yeah that when the man comes and says
hold on a second that's not true or this
that's not how that happened Etc when
you hear both sides you realize that the
the wife was in an emotional place she
was saying things Etc and then things
are more claar like hold on a second
there is a part to blame here and there
both for you so that is why it is so
important that we don't just look at
somebody's emotions even if it's a man
if it comes and says yeah my wife did
this my wife hold on a second bro but
why would your wife do that like why
would your wife just randomly go and do
that did you do something we have to so
any last words you want to say I I
personally on this matter there's
nothing else I have to say anything you
like to say if you do just let me know
in the prophet PE said and I want to
give this advice to our sisters okay
because it's very very important again
the prophet PE told us he went to the
hell fight again I know you guys are
going to be oh it's a reality trick okay
and he saw majority of the woman of the
Hellfire why he said not because they
are ungrateful to Allah because they are
ungrateful to their husbands now when
I'm talking about husband please take
your evil dad who beat up your mom your
evil ex-husband I am not talking about
them throw them in the bin I'm talking
about a good man woman in their nature
have ingratitude sadly so the point is
what the prophet gave a solution because
this is from the prophet don't blame me
so the point is what guys sometimes bear
patience on what not matters that
violate your religion no matters that
he's oppressing you no I'm not talking
about that the prophet P said a man a
woman listen to this carefully and I Le
know this not a woman who protects a
chastity God's a chastity does her basic
Salah her minimum and her husband is
pleased with her brothers and sisters
look at the reward she will be told to
enter Jenna not from a specific door
from any door she
wishes the reason I'm saying this guys
is as men we need to know our
responsibilities and how we need to be
with our wives and the prophet has made
that clear Islam has made it clear
loving them affection repeating it
there's a lot of things men don't do but
what I'm seeing is guys in a nutshell
both of us complete each other so what
I'm going to say is to the sisters that
men if he's a good man if he's a good
husband he prays he fears Allah he looks
after you please don't compare him to
others please don't go and say but he
does that he does that because this in
gratitude like I said before all we're
saying is the following that if your
husband is pleased with you that is your
daughter Jenna if you have a good man
hold on to him and it is only that if we
both come together in our religion get
close to Allah and prioritize that
rather than the worldly things I believe
things will get better anything that I
said wrong is from Shan and myself
anything good is from Allah there's
anything you disagree on no okay are you
under any J you can blink twice no okay
that's fine uh that's all I have to say
in brother sisters again me and my wife
have done this initiative and come
together brother sisters genuinely with
the intention of helping or avoiding the
breakdown of the family unit I hope it
benefits you guys it might be something
that I might regret and take down not
that my wife you know we're not talking
about private life anything she has a
takes it's the first time we're doing
this inshallah you might see this video
delete deleted one day maybe I just I
don't know but what I'm just saying is
guys that we need to be careful and stop
looking at public figures as our role
model in that's all I wanted to say
brother
sisters for myself and my dear wife may
Allah bless you for your contributions
it's a pleasure and a honor uh to have
you here inah and hope you guys like the
idea if you want us to improve it
whatever please next